what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today we have
part two ah screaming
guys you already know i know we've been
promising this for a minute but i went
out and i asked the people is feminism a
hate group
and this is part two of what they said
oh my god i'm so nervous
hi hi
[Music]
i'm i'm pro what's your name i heard you
the past few conversations okay
you're angelica yeah i'm angelica
oh i did not
i had beef with this girl
nice to meet you nice to meet you too so
um my statement is that i think feminism
is a hate group
and i'm going to give you the definition
yeah
um a hate group is a social group that
advocates and practices hostility
hatred or violence towards a member
members of another group like of race or
gender or whatever honestly i didn't
quite hear you all the way okay okay a
hate group is a social group that
advocates and practices hatred hostility
or violence towards members of a race
ethnicity
nation religion gender gender identity
sexual orientation or any
de designated sector of society
right and you're saying that feminism
falls under that category of a hate
group
i disagree so tell me why
i disagree because
i think feminism
means something to each person
individually
and so
you're sort of generalizing a few people
into one group
and that's not necessarily like why i
would be a feminist
or why like people in other countries
would be a feminist
so that's why
i would disagree
so the reason that i think feminism is a
hate group is because oftentimes the
things that they advocate for are at the
cost of men
so i think johnny depp and amber heard
is a perfect example where about five
years ago the idea was believe all women
and i i would say that that that was
feminism that was feminist movement
ideology believe all women and now we're
seeing the effects of that five years
later because a man with money power and
privilege
had his reputation destroyed
what happens to the average man
yeah so i guess that's sort of something
that i was thinking about too with this
whole believe all women because
i i don't think that it's not
it's not necessarily something that i
even believe like during that time
believe all women i think if you're a
true feminist you would
take a look at each story individually
and see what you have to think from that
so i can't identify with someone who
said i believe all women because
i i don't believe anyone like right
without there's some crazy there's some
crazy like girls out there just like
there's crazy guys but i will say that
there
people should believe women more like
for even just in my own experience being
harassed at school
i i didn't have anyone sticking up for
me or for my rights
in fact actually i was sexually harassed
in a stem class a science class i was
one out of two girls in that class and
because i was harassed i had to move my
class
so i didn't have a chance to take a
science class
for that reason
and so to me it's like
well why didn't anyone believe me
but also the bells right now so i don't
know your specific situation but i
but but to me that's at the expense of
men
because if you're saying we should
believe women more than men a lot of the
accusations are against men so so so
in a very real way
because like
no one believed me so it was at my
expense
so what do you have to say about that
about that being at your expense i don't
know the situation i don't know what
happened because because i don't i don't
know you so i can't just believe a story
that i don't i don't know
yeah and i guess that's where i'm just a
person looking at you telling like an
experience that happened to me in my
life i was in eighth grade and i was in
between two desks and
a guy like got himself stuck in between
the desk and was humping me
and because of that i didn't feel safe
in the class
and i told the administration and
i had to change the class
because and it was something everybody
saw
well they should like they should have
taken you into account in that situation
like they like he should have gotten in
trouble i agree with you but it's at my
expense
your expense
right right but what i'm saying is like
i don't i don't think feminists but i
don't think women should be able to just
be believed without evidence
so to me like i shouldn't believe women
more than men because one that's not
equality and two it's at the expense of
men
because you're talking about this case
right where you were at the expense but
i've seen cases where men go to jail for
crimes that they didn't do because a
woman accused them i'm great
i say grave i can't say the r word on
youtube so no you understand like why is
that
it's it's the algorithm oh okay i can't
like get out
so like there's there's men that lose
their entire careers off of a woman's
accusation
just like we've seen in johnny depp and
amber hurt yeah but in the end now you
can see like
the media basically vilified her and
there's no coming back for her and at
the end of the day like both of them
have like mental illness addiction
after after vilifying him for five years
and costing him pirates pirates of the
caribbean he's fine he's a millionaire
he's fine do you see this lack of
empathy for men
she just glossed over
the fact that this man lost his
livelihood for five years she said he'll
be fine what
you think he's fine he that took away
his livelihood but everyone is
supporting him at the end of the day now
five years later people looked at him
like he was
a rapist for years
i honestly i
didn't even hear about the
the article until
the case no the trial
in the us i'm telling you it was huge he
lost he was in the pirate you know what
pirates of the caribbean is of course
yeah so he lost like that was his movie
and they they took him out of it because
of her accusations because at the
because of of the idea we should believe
women over men
[Music]
i think that's probably more a problem
with the media and the fact that the
media tries to
kind of jump on to certain like trends
especially social trends and the fact
that believe all women was something
that
was picking up speed
i think the media is trying to make
money always
and so
they have to appeal to women and so
believe all women
it makes sense but what i'm saying i
believe that but that's just how the
world works you kind of do because even
before you said we should believe women
over men i never said that i have it on
camera you did you said we should
believe women more than that
i never said that but
yes you did
okay i will say that
there
people should believe women more like
well i don't i didn't phrase it the
correct way but i would say that i don't
think that you should
believe men over the expense of women in
the terms of like i mean you say like
you don't know my personal case but like
the world is made out of individual
cases the world isn't like a big
generalized group that you can say like
you know believe all women like if
you're a real person in a day-to-day
life like you don't generally believe
all of something like
you have your own personal beliefs from
the world that you see around you right
but i'm talking about a movement so i'm
talking about feminism as a movement
and that was a movement that feminism
pushed
but
who is like feminism too like there's
not like a head of the feminist
community there's not like
like if you want to look at a real
feminine feminist you could look at
malala yosavasi who was shot in the head
by the taliban and she is arguably the
leader of feminism i would say today
and that's an actual hate group
i mean i think we would agree that like
the taliban is bad to like all together
yes
yeah but i'm saying that that's someone
who is arguably like the head of the
feminist movement right but what i'm
talking about is that feminism advocates
for things at the cost of men and i'm
saying even in this conversation like
you even said yourself you should
believe women over men and it's like
that ideology is what i'm talking about
i don't remember saying i believe
believe
women over men i personally
don't really believe that but i'm also
curious about like for example in terms
of like collecting evidence
how should
how should i be believed like well i
think something were to happen to me how
should i believe like what kind of
evidence are you looking for
exactly what evidence right um well i
think it's innocent until proven guilty
yeah so so like sexual harassment or
sexual assault it's pretty hard to prove
when that has happened to you
so i think that if you're going to say
like feminism is a hate group you should
also have like
maybe some idea about how to solve some
of the issues for women
that you know women particularly do face
like sexual harassment or sexual
violence i think women are the number
one victims of sexual violence all over
the world
i'm trying to tread carefully
if if somebody's going around graping
women right he he either
people have patterns of behavior so if
you don't have the evidence
it will be likely that someone in the
future will also come forward and have
the same story
and if you get a bunch of people that
have the same story and have all tried
to press charges again you can make a
better case
like
if you go get a grape kit the day after
like there's ways you can collect
evidence and convict someone that's
guilty
it's not like this
process
that it's impossible to convict someone
you just need to have the evidence and
modern women like want to be able to
convict men without the evidence
well men are more likely to be victims
of a violent crime than women
that's because men are more violent
obviously
well it means it depends
it depends because like in domestic
violence cases when it's one-sided
unreciprocated
women are more likely to to abuse their
partner and not be reciprocated
i'm sorry i didn't know so women are
more likely to abuse their partner and
it's not reciprocated so if you look at
so if you look at abusive couples right
most of the time they're abusing each
other and if you look at the cases where
it's not retaliated it means one's
hitting the other and they're not abused
back
women are more likely to do that to men
than men are to women
i don't know where you get that
information from where's that
information from
it's a documentary it's called yeah it's
called um
it's like about this girl she basically
like dove into feminism and dove into
like the men's rights movement
i can i can get it for you i'm not just
like making this up but yeah i can get
it for you what do you think that you
the youtube channel
yeah
um okay it's um
destroy the director
okay yeah i'll check it out did you did
you check it out
but personally like i can't really speak
on information that
like like we said believable women like
i don't know you like that's fair yeah
yeah yeah that's fair that's fair
and in my life experience i've
definitely seen men
be more violent towards women and i
haven't ever seen a woman
be violent towards her partner i've seen
girls hit guys and nobody does anything
i haven't seen that
and i what kind of hit like a little
knock on the shoulder or like any hit is
unacceptable and if you if you hit a man
you should expect to get hit back
yeah
um why would you hit someone and not
expect to get hit back
men don't have that like
why are women special
why do we get a special privilege that
men don't get if if he hits him he's
getting hit back
i don't think anyone should be hitting
anybody i agree i was just meaning like
in a playful conversation like when you
hit someone's shoulder or something okay
you're talking about like
yeah i don't mean like actual violence
but
i don't know i haven't really seen women
being violent towards men if you have in
your own life then
i would have to ask you where you're
from
where you see that
you see men being violent towards women
all the time
i've definitely
had situations in my personal life
where my friends have been victims of
domestic
abuse
but here's the thing she didn't say that
she witnessed it or she saw the
situation happen so again you're just
going off of someone's word why because
she believes women more than men
what do you know
where what say that again where a friend
of mine has been a victim of domestic
abuse
or
like marital abuse from a family
situation
so
that's i haven't seen like
i don't know and also though like
it is true that men shouldn't be hit
like how
he can't really defend himself
but he can also leave the situation a
lot easier than a woman who is being
abused because they're typically
smaller than their partners
and physically
not the same like kind of match
okay guys you'll notice this trend with
modern women and feminists
whenever you try to hold a woman
accountable they move the goal post and
say well but he could leave
imagine imagine let's let's flip this
flip the script right
if she
she's getting hit girls getting hit well
she could have laughed she could leave
is that
is that right is that how we should talk
you think men are believed
when they're victims of domestic abuse
maybe not in the past but i think now
now more especially after this johnny
depp
situation
okay okay well um i appreciate you
sitting down and talking to me
yeah i mean you've been going for a
while yeah i see you out here doing this
but
i i'm just wondering like from myself
who i watched you do this um a few few
different interviews
um but i'm just wondering like what
exactly are you getting from these kind
of conversations do you find that you
yourself are learning more about people
or are you just kind of pushing the
agenda
because to me like honestly i just heard
kind of like you're sticking to the same
talking points and i didn't really hear
a lot of like discussion from your end
and to me i just get public opinions on
stuff so i just get people's public
opinions and i also i have um
bro a lot of the reason i do what i do
is i advocate for men's rights
so i have two brothers that like
committed they tried to commit suicide
so i just think the world is harder for
men than the media really lets it be and
i i think feminism yeah i think it's
it's tough on bad i don't think they
advocate for men the way they should
so i'm sorry to hear that yeah
but also
it's
if we uplift women
men will also be uplifted too
okay if you uplift women for what for
being women why should we just be
uplifted for being alive
like that's the stupidest [ __ ] i've ever
heard in my life like okay
let's let's uplift men for just being
men like no
no
freaking
and so it's not
one without the other like surely we do
uplift women
all the time
there's women's empowerment all the time
there's no men's empowerment
but are you aware about the abortion
rights in the united states and
what do you have to say about that like
women i think just had their rights
taken away from abortion and certainly i
don't need the right to an abortion i'm
careful with who i sleep with and i use
protection yeah but why do i need the
right to an abortion if you're raped
that's that's less than one percent of
abortions
so
let's talk about the 99 of abortions
because that's what girls do when they
don't have a good argument they look for
the exception to the rule that's the
exception
i know people who have been raped and so
a lot of rapes also go under reported
because it's a very shameful thing to
happen to women and also they don't have
the evidence and so it's even more
shameful to go and accuse someone of a
crime when they don't have evidence what
evidence do you have that is
under-reported how do you know how do
you know how do you know that it's
underreported
um because women who get raped don't 100
always go and report it
how do you know
because i know people that that has
happened to how do you know by and large
that that's a big issue because you're
just automatically believing women
without the evidence
which goes back to what i'm doing which
goes back to what i'm saying if my
friend has trauma and she's shaking like
this we're not talking we're not we're
not talking about individuals we're
talking about by and large yeah but one
group comprises one person is a part of
a group and a group
for example feminism isn't um
like there is not a president of
feminism there isn't someone saying this
is the objective of feminism that
doesn't exist the group is comprised of
people with individual stories with
their own individual but i need but i
need facts data and statistics for you
to back it up if somebody is saying so
if you look at statistics for example
you can look at something like
unemployment you know how unemployment
is calculated
unemployment is calculated by
when someone is actively looking for a
job but once they stop looking for a job
then it's no longer part of the
calculation
and so that skews the statistic
you can think also about rape statistic
if someone isn't reporting
what has happened to them
how can you have a statistic about
something being under-reported if
they haven't reported it of course i can
say my friend that has happened to my
friend because that's a real story that
i know
so how how could i honestly like answer
a statistic of something that's been
under-reported
there is no reportage of that that
doesn't make logical sense no but i'm
saying you need to have some date like
if we're talking about abortion right
that's what we're talking about and i
said less than one percent of abortions
are are for great okay and so you said
oh well it's underreported so i said
okay if that's your argument then give
me data that a large percentage of those
grapes are from abortion and it doesn't
seem like you have it is there any data
that shows that all rape that has been
reported
has been i'm not i'm not i
i'm not saying that every single grape
is is reported what what i'm saying is
you you need to prove that it's by and
large a problem where where
it's statistically significant because
it's like we're moving the goal post
here because i said let's talk about the
99 of abortions instead of the one
percent the exception and you're you're
trying to imply it's not an exception
and i'm gonna say if you're gonna say
it's not an exception i need some data
or evidence that that's true because if
that's what you're saying then you're
going back to the original argument
which is we just believe all women
it's not believe all women but it's
believe like individual stories that you
paid attention to that you understand
the background
and those things are comprised of like
feminine that's the feminist movement is
individual stories so you can't
generalize and say if i know
if i know you personally sure i might
i'll probably believe a friend if i know
her personally but if i don't know you
why would i just believe you
if i don't if i don't know you
personally and you're not gonna go
report it
then what is the point you're trying to
say my point is that you're moving the
goal post and we're talking about
abortion i'm saying let's talk about the
99 of abortion
what about that are not for and you're
saying you're saying it's a woman's
right to choose that's what we're
talking about that we're losing our
rights about abortion right that's what
we're talking about in the united states
i know that there's been a law that
maybe has been amended or something like
that
where some the abortion rights have been
taken away so and i'm talking i'm saying
i don't think that's a right like that
we deserve to have like i don't need
that right i'm careful with who i sleep
with
like why is it the government's right to
tell me that i can't
abort something from my body why is it
your right to kill a baby
it's not a baby
and why can't we just be more
responsible and take accountability as
women for who we sleep with and then you
keep going to the exception to the rule
which is rape and i'm saying no let's
talk about the ninety-nine percent of
them like if you actually have been
raped like doesn't that matter
i'm not talking about but i'm talking
about 99 of abortions and i can't you
can't stay on topic
because you look for the exception like
fine i'll give you the rape abortion
because let's talk about the 99 percent
the not i don't think any of it should
be allowed but for the focus of this
conversation to try to get you to stay
on point you're raped and you're
pregnant no no we're talking about 99
of abortions that's what we're talking
about what about the one percent i'm
sure it's thousands of people
i just said that i would give you the
one percent
so let's talk about the 99
why is that a woman's right to choose
because it's her body but what about the
baby's body and also sometimes like it's
not like every person who gets pregnant
has an easy pregnancy like there are
certain health issues that occur
so
if your health is jeopardized by the
child that's that's again you this is
what this is what like
it's an exception yes it is
yes it is it's really not true and
actually i know people who have had
abortions because the child actually
would have damaged their like body
who do you know
like
that every horror story that could
possibly happen has happened where where
are you from that's what i want to know
where are you from
just because you know people that have
had abortions doesn't mean that it's a
statistic statistically significant
problem across the board like again
you're looking for an exception rather
than the rule and i wanna and i wanna
bring it back to the original point i'm
asking you why why do we need that right
i already said that i already said my
reason why because it's my body
and if i don't wanna have a child then
it's my right to not have that child and
also there can be an a plethora of
reasons why someone doesn't want to have
a child for example health reasons
and like i i just mentioned i know but
i'm talking about the accept that's the
exception rather than the rule and so if
we're going to say it's my body what
about the baby's body
the baby is not existing at that point
you know you can get an abortion in the
uk up to six months
i think it should be that way so if
you're trying to
so at what point you're trying to say a
fetus is the same thing as a living
human being who has been birthed to me
it's not the same thing and so i have to
respectfully disagree with that point of
view because if it's in the womb it's
not
it's not born
it's not a life
so at what point does it become a baby
i would say post birth so you'd be cool
with an abortion two days before you're
gonna give birth
uh i don't think there's anyone who
would go through an entire pregnancy and
then get an abortion two days before
giving birth i wanna hear the law
exceptions no i'm not i'm talking i'm
talking about a logical consistency like
you need to have a specific point where
it's not a kid and it's not a kid you
just said you want to have um
no exceptions and you just said you want
to have an appointment no i'm i'm asking
no no no i'm out i'm not that it's not
what i said you're not listening i said
what what point is it a baby
and you said birth so i'm asking you at
that with that do you think someone
should be legally able to get an
abortion that's a woman's right two days
before a month before like where is the
line that's what i'm asking you
i would say if someone wants to have an
abortion two days before they give birth
that's their right and i think that's a
hell of a lot of effort to go through an
entire pregnancy and to give the baby up
two days before i don't understand why
someone would do that but fundamentally
i believe that that is their right
because the baby is not
alive yet but at the same time i'm
pretty sure if you had a c-section uh at
nine months the baby would be alive so
uh i don't know you're okay i'm curious
if you know actually if you've had
children um
if you know about the process of being
pregnant because there's a lot of health
complications involved so
i'm just curious why you would have a
stance so strongly against abortion
especially when abortion has actually
saved women's lives
in instances it's also killed women's
lives because half of abortions are
women
they're not women they're fetuses
or embryos they're not even like right
they have a unique dna sequence that
says their personality their eye color
their hair color like from from the
moment of conception
i already said that what i believe and i
don't believe a fetus is you know that's
fine that's fine well i appreciate you
stopping by
no idea it makes good content actually i
prefer talking to people that disagree
so thanks for coming
i think i'm going to try to go to the
next person
thank you for
having this platform yeah
but i'm definitely
pro-choice yeah that's fine yeah it's
okay we should just agree together and i
think all women
should be
not me but
all right
you guys want to come next
oh come on come on don't love you you'll
find a husband on my channel come on
you'll get like three marriage proposals
i swear to god
i don't know i feel like
okay so that's it i'm just curious i see
this like on youtube debates and i think
it's really interesting okay this girl
was literally the sweetest that was one
of my favorite people i've interviewed
like she was so nice
yeah yeah so um i think feminism is a
hate group and i'm gonna give you the
definition of a hate group
a hate group is a social group that
advocates and practices hatred hostility
and violence towards members of a race
ethnicity national
nation religion gender gender identity
sexual okay another group basically
um what do you think of that
i don't know hate group it's quite
strong okay i see
i think
okay
i feel like i'm going to be cancelled
this is something i feel like feminist
feminism now it's quite toxic
okay or i feel like when it started it
had a different purpose maybe
um then now
yeah so i don't and if i would say hate
group okay i definitely know like people
that are feminists i wouldn't say that
they're like extreme extreme in that
sense but i see there's a lot of things
that
people that call themselves feminists do
that are quite hateful so and yeah why
do you think it's okay for women to say
men are trash have you heard that before
yeah i don't think it's okay
but why like as a society it's
acceptable for us as women to say men
are trash men are trash but if you hear
women or horrors like it's like ah
yeah i think
i also think like
men don't want women to feel
bad or hated or like excluded
so i think um
don't know i don't know why is it okay i
don't think it's okay i feel like
there's a double standard regarding to
that i think
when people i heard that growing up like
i had friends that say that and i just
thought it was a bit wrong because if it
was the other way around they would they
would think yeah it's just not okay so i
always wonder why is it okay for them to
say that
um
i don't know why as a society we accept
that i think there's nothing like
as a society we want people to be on the
same level
and
because
women have been you know historically
oppressed in a sense
and they had like a few rights that they
wanted and they didn't get it for a long
time
i feel like society wants to make up for
that so when women say
i don't know yeah i know i know how to
explain it i i think there's no
explanation
in the end yeah
why don't you think we have you heard
feminists talk about equal pay
yeah
so why don't you think we see why don't
we see feminists marching the street for
only fans models and just models the
women that get paid more than the men
i don't know yeah
i don't think
yeah i think in europe we have
we don't have so much of an issue maybe
with a copay or i've seen some
statistics that kind of
prove that wrong or
some people talking about that
how it's not really true yeah you're
right yeah so
i don't know yeah because the reason
it's wrong is because they just divide
like what women make um and they don't
take into account things like the number
of hours worked so if me and you are
going for a job and i work 10 hours a
week for 20 years and you work eight
hours a week for 20 years who's gonna
make more yeah and actually one of my
it's not very like nowadays it's not
really popular for people to say that
yeah but one of my co-workers funny
enough brought it up and he's a man and
he was he asked me if you asked for a
raise how much would you ask for and i
said i'll probably ask for like 5 000
more and he said well i'll definitely
ask for seven thousand more at least and
i was like oh wow i don't know if i'd go
that high but that yeah i think 5000 is
my
limit so i kind of realized that you
know people also like men also usually
ask for raises more quickly and like
higher raises as well so i think that
could also be a factor they're more
willing to also take more
responsibility yeah you're correct 60 of
women have never in their lifetime asked
for a raise
wow
i i i can see that i i think i wouldn't
too i i hate negotiate i for this
channel i i have a guy i give a
percentage of like the money to because
i hate negotiating i have him do it for
me because i just think as a woman we
don't like conflict yeah i think i
wouldn't negotiate but not like straight
up like my my co-worker was like i would
negotiate like really soon i was like
okay i need to show that i'm good enough
to negotiate for this price but yeah
it's like
and if they say no like i was just like
oh okay
where i think the men are more likely to
like fight for it you know what i mean
yeah yeah i could definitely see that
yeah i think i had to like train myself
to be able to say no more yeah and be
more confrontational so i'm okay with
saying that but i can definitely see
that people would not be able to yeah
it's the trade agreeableness so women
are more agreeable than men because in
history we had to learn to get along
with a man if we wanted to survive so we
don't like conflict we're men if they
wanted to survive they had to enter
conflict and win
yeah
yeah i also i watch like jordan we do
some videos sometimes yeah and he talks
about how um women also need like they
need more agreeableness to be able to
take care of the child and i think
that's crazy that i never thought about
it like psychologically that kind of
makes sense
so yeah yeah i kind of agree yeah well
do you have any socials you want to plug
this was such a fun conversation
my audience will like you that's i don't
really use instagram that much i tried
to like stay off okay of instagram how
old are you um 20 or 20 yeah
yeah
and and are you single
yeah i'm not really looking for anyone i
was gonna say my audience will love you
they're like a girl without instagram
sign me up
i do have instagram everybody's like for
friends namely i got you i got you all
right i think what's your name my name
is pearl nice to meet you it's the
channel's just pearly yeah i just i yeah
i just raised it up yeah okay have a
good one yeah good luck with everything
thank you thank you
what's your name amel
sorry amel yeah okay that's a pretty
name um what
okay let me pull up so my assertion
today is that i think feminism is a hate
group
and a hate group is a social group that
advocates and practices hatred hostility
or violence towards members of a race
ethnicity nation religion gender gender
identity sexual orientation or every any
other designated sector of society
do you agree or disagree i disagree okay
why
um i don't think it's a hate group i
don't think the the big
i don't know how to say this but the big
thing that
feminism feminism wants to talk about i
don't think it's about hatred i think
it's about equality i think it's about
representation i think it's about just
opening a conversation i don't know why
you think it's a hate group and it's not
about so it's hate about
men or other people it's just about
wanting the things things in the same
opportunities and the same voices
my question to you is what in 2022 what
opportunities are women not afforded
that that men are i mean in certain
places like feminism i think sorry just
depress i just want to in the west so
england in the us just to probably
i just want to say i'm not from
the uk or the us
i'm from france actually
but i just can't speak on that
for me feminism it's about not only
fighting for yourself but for all the
women
all the women
around the world so
women who don't have the same
opportunities that uh
women from the uk or from france or from
the us have because that's just the fact
they don't what so what opportunities do
we not have like in the france the uk us
what do we not have i mean in certain
places there's still discrimination
about women you're not taking with the
same credibility uh as men
from experiences
they still have um like harassment
sexual harassment going on i mean the
97 percent uh you know a phrase that i
like it's it's not all men but it's all
women you know
do you not as a woman have any um
problems or like
aggressions
or like um commentaries or
about because you're a woman or
sexualized at a young age or stuff like
that you know
whatever was i sexualized at a young no
i was pretty ugly
i think it's not i don't know
i think it's deeper than that i think
it's not about if you're ugly if you're
pretty or not i think if
you just people just will
sexualize you in
many different forms do you think women
sexualize ourselves though you see girls
like taking off their clothes and like
getting like from a young age you see
girls taking off their clothes and
getting on social media what do you mean
young age like like i mean my sister's
16 15 she
i see her friends they're like in
bikinis and like like shoving their
boobs and like shaking their butt on
social media like they're sexualizing
themselves yeah so i think do you think
the problems is them or not the person
sexualizing them i think it's both i
mean i think you can't take
accountability from women like if you're
gonna if i walked around here butt naked
i can't be mad if men sexualize me i
mean that's silly
no one's asking you to be but naked but
i think if a 16 year old girl just wants
to have fun and just want to get a
picture with her friends and not
expecting to be sexualized that
immediately and just want to have uh
just a picture with her friends looking
good and
you know it's not just that like i i
have tick tock there's 16 year old
shaken shaking butt it's not like
they're just taking a picture at the
beach they're shaking ass at a young age
and i think as like an older generation
of women we need to
like tell younger women like that's
that's unacceptable behavior
because like men the wrong you're going
to get the wrong type of attention
i mean but you're taking all the
accountability off of the woman and just
putting it all on the mat
i don't
maybe i think
feminism is about having a choice i
think if someone wants so quickly
but naked that's the [ __ ] choice i'm
not going to say that you can do that
because i don't agree with that that's
your life i wouldn't do it personally
but i won't judge you it will force you
to not do it i agree with you like i
think women should have the choice to do
whatever they want to choose like within
reason i think there should be like
nudity laws you know like like
right yeah we'd agree okay but um but at
the same time like
at the same time i think you need to
warn women of the outcomes and if you
dress a certain way and you act a
certain way like i'm not gonna i have
three little sisters and i tell them if
you dress a little a certain way and you
act a certain way men are going to look
at you a certain way and you don't want
them to look at you like that so you
agree you agree that the problem is the
men's sexual lack oh i think dangerous
for them no i mean partially i mean
partially i think there's creepy men i
agree with you i don't think it's the
majority of men i think it's a minority
i think it's a small percentage of men
but
but what i do think is like you have to
take some accountability as women for
the way we're we're acting and
presenting ourselves and i'm not just
going to put all the blame on men you're
not pulling all the blame on men you're
actually minimizing the suffering of
women who have experienced like rape
sexual grace aggressions and things like
that on an everyday basis or
at least
minimizing the experience of those women
when i'm just talking about female
accountability because you're putting
all the blame on women and you're just
not realizing the things and say you
shouldn't do that because that's the
outcome that's gonna get no no
that's not what i'm doing i'm saying i
want women to be able to protect
themselves and and there are so there
there there are shitty men but it's not
a
a majority it's a minority it's a small
percentage of men that commit a lot of
crimes and so why would i not tell my
sisters to protect themselves and dress
a certain way i also don't want my
sisters to be known as like a ho
i don't i don't want i don't want my
like thumb to be known as that so i i'm
saying we need to take some
accountability as women because we're
talking we're not even talking about
assault we were talking about being
sexualized like having men look at you
and if you walk around half naked like
we can't be shocked if the men look
i mean
i think you're very lucky if you think
that it's a minority and
that women don't experience that
in that it doesn't affect them
that it doesn't affect them and
i think women just want to have fun and
just how they want you're lucky if you
think that it doesn't happen every day
or that it doesn't affect the women as
much as you think it does because
i don't think women who post themselves
on social media
automatically want them want to be
sexualized or want this type of
attention i think they just want to have
fun and
not
having to think about oh it's going to
get this attention or it's going to get
that or this you know and just oh i look
good i want to post myself and my
friends because it was a good time and i
think i look
nice so why not so you don't think women
ever sexualize themselves i think they
don't i think they do
and i don't think there is a problem
with that okay but i'm not
i'm what i'm not saying is there's a
problem i think people should be able to
do what they want to do but what i am
saying is if you're choosing to post
those images online you can't be mad if
people sexualize you like i'm not going
to victimize
women that are getting like sexualized
and this is not to be confused with
assault we're talking about being sexual
um i think
some girls definitely want to be
sexualized and
not in a bad way in a way like oh i
think i look good maybe i want this type
of attention i think that's okay because
why not
but not every everyone sometimes you
just want to post yourself and not have
creepy money in your dms
saying
disgusting stuff you know and some
people some girls do but why don't you
just turn off your message requests
like it's pretty easy yeah but
turn off your comments turn it like turn
it off again you're just uh doing uh
making all the the wrongs and all the
the bad luck on the women and not on the
men why you're putting the blame on
women and not on the men who are creepy
and
sending this dirty message it's like
i'll say the same thing like this is
what we're talking about
and then they they just move the goal
post it's like let's just not talk about
what we're suppose
what's the difference between a man
being creepy and a man that is
interested in you i think
you you you you seeing the difference
you feel the difference how the phrases
are made how
it's based on how attracted you are to
him
no i think
even if it's a
a hot man a hot guy who
gets uh who will uh comment on a post or
a picture and we'll be like uh oh i
think you're [ __ ] sexy i wanna [ __ ]
you or disgusting things i will still
say [ __ ] you man get out you know you
don't think women do the same thing
what do you mean
you don't think women do the same thing
they don't think they sexualize men
and send creepy messages to men
i think yes but the thing is feminism
it's about it's not about oh women did
that oh men did that no it's about
yeah man feminism is just about having a
choice i think for for me personally i
think it's just opening doors and
opportunities and giving voices to
people who don't have one and
and you know talk about it well i just
want to know like what is holding us
back in 2022
like i haven't heard anything holding us
back like if anything
being sexualized gives women more
opportunity only fans stripping men
can't do that
i mean
i think you're saying that i mean as a
white girl i don't i don't think you
have the same struggles also
as other women and
that plays a huge part i don't think you
can speak on other women like uh what
are sending us back you don't you and i
don't have the same struggles
what struggles like what what struggles
do women have i just i need you to like
tell me what they are i mean as a woman
i don't like having to
walk back home with my kids between my
hands because i'm scared someone will
[ __ ] men are more likely to be
victims of a violent crime
i really
don't
women don't get raped women don't get us
they men get assaulted and grape too you
know that men didn't weren't even
they didn't even count men being raped
until like
as a feminism as a feminist sorry
i'm as much as
as much supporting
men victims as women victims i think
that's a huge part of feminism i think
if you are a feminist you should give
voices also to men who are victims of
sexual violence and stuff like that then
why do we have phrases like believe all
women
because the rates of
false accusation are
0.01 percent it's actually a really
really small percentage
of false socialization
does this woman just know
every single person that's gone through
every single traumatic experience ever
like she sure knows a lot of exceptions
seven percent seven percent it's
it's actually a really small percentage
what about the oh
seven men's lives
where are you getting your facts from
where am i getting my facts from
they're from different studies that have
been done
what are your studies
that is
i can pull them up for you i have a
whole link they're going to be linked in
the description i have links too okay
well no that's fine so you're saying
it's point zero one percent
uh i think it's a really really small
percentage
okay okay but but my point is like in
the name of equality like why isn't that
a hot button issue
what did you say like why why don't like
johnny depp had his entire career ruined
and he's a man with power fame and
influence what does that mean for the
average man
as you can see uh though the whole uh
justice for johnny depp was trending on
twitter i think a whole part of them now
siding with
and
now but he lost his career for five
years everyone everyone thought he he
was a rapist because we said believe all
women and that's a man with power money
and influence so how can we see that
feminism is advocating for men when
feminism allowed that to happen
i don't think it's feminism that allowed
that to happen i think believe all women
was a feminist movement yes i do but i
think that
amber heard
used that use that statement and use
that power to
her advantage she used that to uh to to
you know to get on the good side to be
like oh i'm a part of
all women and i have lived that and now
the trial uh proved that it was false
but
the only
student take the blame on all other
women who did live those experiences and
who are you know real victims you can
sign in their voices and just be like uh
oh no don't believe all women because
amber heard did that so i don't say
don't believe all women i say believe
the evidence
and they gave her an op-ed with no
evidence
none that that wouldn't happen for a man
i mean um so if we're so concerned with
equality like
like why was that allowed to happen
because it's the justice system
unfortunately it wasn't through the
justice system i mean uh social media
played a huge part in it but you know
you can't
blame everything on that you just agreed
it was a feminist movement believe all
women like you
but so so i'm saying this was the result
of a feminist movement and that's why i
think it's a hate group because it was
at the cost of men
do you not see all the good things that
feminism gave to women to all people to
people in general i think it it opened
the conversations it opened uh
uh it gave voices to people who don't
have one it gave a lot of things
personally it helped me
they open the conversation but it can't
just be to anyone
just because you're a woman like i don't
think every every woman you can i think
everyone should have an opportunity to
say what they want and to share their
stories whether it's true or false you
have the right that's a birthright you
can share your experience i mean if it's
false alright that's not my issue
you have to say it after
you personally every person has to
think for themselves and see oh do i
believe it or do i or i don't that's
personal you know
i i agree but my point is i don't think
the media should be giving platforms to
women with no evidence just off the fact
that they're women
like so if you you okay so let's say you
had a story i don't know you right but
let's just say you had a story you had
no evidence let's say it was against
some some famous guy it would be
irresponsible on my part to give you a
platform if you had no evidence that
that happened so i should just shut up
you should press charges i mean a lot of
women do
but it doesn't get past that
it's not that easy it's really not that
easy
i can say it from experience it's not
that easy people don't take you
seriously or it doesn't get through or
people who
imagine i'm getting assaulted by
men in power i can do anything if i
don't have a platform if i just report
it it's not going to get passed because
they have the lawyers they have a lot of
stuff that i don't so i will be
defenseless so having a platform is the
only thing that can protect me okay so i
just want to like follow this train of
thought so
you think that i should
it would be responsible of me like let's
say that happened okay
if you you had this story against this
politician for me to give you a platform
with no evidence
i mean
i wouldn't say no evidence but i mean if
you would a story
i mean if you want to talk about it i'm
not going to say no shut up don't say it
because i don't agree with you if you
want to say it say it i mean all people
will have an opportunity to to speak in
that's freedom of speech you know right
i'm all for freedom of speech but when
it becomes defamation of character
that's when i have an issue
so when it becomes
we we can give any girl a platform
and we just believe her regardless of
the facts and the data and the
statistics and the evidence that's when
i have a problem because that comes at
the cost of men
because men can lose their lives and
their reputations off of one accusation
that that could turn out to be false
so i think it is irresponsible of women
for us to just give any girl that
platform just based on the fact that
she's a woman what about the women's
lives who are ruined after leaving a
traumatic event that that ruins life but
you're moving the goal post here
wait like like i'm i'm asking you about
this situation and instead of responding
you're changing the topic i'm not saying
because i didn't like what you said i
mean if you everyone can have their
lives ruined i think if it's if that's
false if the accusation is false then
you can prove it
you know
so that wouldn't hurt you as no you
can't no you can't if you if you if you
just say if i
should have the evidence to go to to
have a platform to speak
you sure you should have evidence too to
prove that it's false you should have
one if it didn't happen i'm saying it
should be innocent until proven guilty
that's what i said i said we should
assume that he is innocent until it's
proven that he is guilty
and no but i don't think you do because
you're saying oh he should have evidence
that he didn't didn't do it that's
guilty until proven that's guilty until
proven innocent because you're
automatically assuming that he should
have evidence if you if you if you hook
up with a guy and sleep with him
consensually and then after you say it
was that it was
oh sorry sorry if you hook up with a guy
okay and and you say that it was um
non-consensual after okay
how would he prove that if you guys did
sleep together and it was consensual how
would he prove it i mean i i think you
should definitely filter
the
everyone can go to
a platform and say whatever they want i
definitely think you should filter those
the
the stories you can say like that uh
just to see it's
i think you i think you shouldn't go to
like um
a platform or something you can
talk about it in public if you don't
have
anything
but most people do
most people who go
to these platforms or stuff to talk
about their stories they they have some
backgrounds you're stupid if you don't
it's okay
but okay so we kind of agree on some
level right at least a little bit
could you go around um we agree on on
the level that it should be innocent
until proven guilty right we shouldn't
there should be some betting on who we
let on the public platform right yeah
but it has nothing to do with feminism
that's just the law i would say that
no it's not the law
i mean and isn't it
until proven guilty is uh
i'm talking about the court of public
opinion
you can't uh control everyone that's
you just can't you just can't say uh i
don't want uh
people to have this platform you you
can't people are gonna do that the world
is gonna it's gonna be this way and
there's more uh help from the from this
than damages i think
there is damages i'm not saying there
isn't but just because of the amber herd
story is not gonna be uh what do you
mean just because if this happened to a
man with power money and influence how
many men has this happened to how many
women has this happened to that's what
happened too
and not being
heard not being taking uh
not having credibility not being able to
to be believed
and i think that's unfortunate the most
cases the point is like there has to be
evidence like you it has to be
it has to be based off the evidence not
just shared exterior experiences and
story
it should be the uh the same for the
other way around too correct
i think both ways around it it has to be
based on evidence
if it's
the same for the other way around then i
agree if it's just about women then i
don't agree but my point is that like
feminism pushed believe all women and it
was at the expense of men
like that's my point
is if if feminism really was about
equality it would have been believed all
women and men but it wasn't
i think real feminists know that you
should believe men as much as women
when it comes to
uh stuff like that i think the real
feminists
know the difference and if they don't
i don't agree with that okay so so then
we would somewhat we agree a little bit
right on that a little bit i mean yeah a
little bit i mean
okay okay so what do you think um i
wanted to go back to a question i had
earlier in 2022 what specific policy
would you say feminists are fighting for
i think
i can't speak for all feminists because
you know i'm just speaking for me
for me
i think it's important because i have
in my history in my family
i am
originally um i'm
moroccan and algerian and you know uh
you don't
back then back there you know in morocco
some
not all women have the power of choice
you know you don't have
everything that we women
like france or like uk or us have and
that's what i'm fighting for okay so you
would say it's abortion
abortion oh you said of choice is that
that when you said choice i thought you
meant like abortion choice no
i mean if you want to talk about
abortion i'm pro-choice yes
no i just meant what did you what were
you referring to when you said um
like what we're still fighting for you
said choice so i thought you were
talking about abortion but you could
have been oh like
as an example like arranging marriages
or stuff like that you know having the
power to say oh i want to choose my
husband or i want to
live my life the way i want to you know
i i would probably i would agree with
you on arranged marriages i do i do
think that's a problem well i don't know
enough about it but like i could see
that but
um i just like in terms of doing what we
want to do i don't think we're held back
in any way
i could i can be whatever i want to be
i'm in a male this is a pretty male
dominated like youtube's mostly men and
i do great in it and i worked in sales i
was really good at that and
i there's nothing stopping me from
getting that job or following that
opportunity so like a lot of times when
i see women talking about not having the
choice to do something it comes off as
an excuse
i think some people definitely use it as
an excuse
i think there's a big difference between
feminism and white feminism but what you
what i wanted to say is uh
that maybe you don't have um struggles
because you're a woman and you don't
have uh you know
things setting you back
but
the thing is feminism is about fighting
for the p the women that
don't have the the the chances that you
have and you know fighting for them
because you know you have
um the privilege so you fight for those
who don't
what i'm saying what in the west what
prep like what do we not have
so i'm not talking about specifically
you understood what i said i mean if you
as a person say you don't have uh
struggles you don't have
problems because you're a woman okay
fine you're lucky good but you know some
a lot of women don't have the
privilege that you have and you know
feminism is about fighting for them you
know if you don't have that okay
but i'm saying like i need specifics
like what specifically do is holding
women back in 2022
in the west
i think sexual violence is still a big
problem i think equal pay in every
state or every country is still a big
problem well equal pay isn't like the
the pay gap has been debunked multiple
times
no yes it has any any social scientists
worth of salt will tell you that the pay
gap doesn't exist when you take and do
things no that
you're you're wrong on this i'm telling
you because you don't take into account
the way they they calculate the pay gap
is
they just look at how much men make
versus how much women make but that's
that's the problem they don't take into
account how many hours women work and
how many hours men work they don't take
into account what jobs women pick and
what jobs men pick men pick fields that
make more money they choose that and if
you look at the countries that have the
most choice
women make less and it's because they
choose careers with people as opposed to
things
you know when you said that men
choose careers where they have
more money things like that uh i think a
lot of women don't have the same
opportunities so maybe they want to uh
to have
those same careers but can because uh
it's mostly a male dominated field
so that's a struggle why can't they they
can join it they have quotas they have
specific quotas and grants
like they're begging women to join
engineering but engineers i don't want
to be an engineer
no i know but i'm saying what i'm saying
is like you're you're making it seem
like like there's something holding
women back and i'm saying when it comes
to pay and income
when it when it comes to pay and income
there's nothing holding women back in
the west
like it's it's them picking jobs that
make less money
i don't agree because you know
you can't speak for all women like i'm
not trying to speak for all women and it
seems like you do
and that's what i i don't like
what i'm doing is i'm taking away i i
don't like women not being held
accountable and i don't like women
blaming the world for their problems
when it's what we choose to do
we choose to work less
we do we work less out we choose to not
ask for raises 60 of women have never
asked for a raise so how are we going to
blame the men when we don't even
negotiate
you say we like you speak for all women
no i'm talking about spax data and
statistics and you're talking about like
you don't have any data to break
i mean
this is like random i get it but you
know you have you come here uh with your
i don't even know how to say that
yeah your sign and
you know i think you're prepared for
this uh i just i get it this is random
yeah but i mean we don't have the same
uh
thoughts the same arguments but you know
uh
i'm not
i'm not trying to speak for everyone i'm
just talking for me personally and i
will never
assume
that my opinion is every woman's opinion
or what i'm thinking is every what every
woman is speaking i'm just speaking for
me yeah i know i know i mean i don't i
don't most women don't agree with me
so so so i get it
but if you think about
why you and the way you do it most women
don't agree with you
oh i gotta get better at the mic
it's okay
no
it because i look at the evidence and
the data and
the other women don't
no they don't because i talk to them all
the time and they never have it
i mean you when you talk to them
all the time you come you have them when
they're on the street when you have your
whole thing packed up and
ready and you're
bro it's like
the condescending comments
that they
it's like sometimes i don't really think
they realize how unpleasant they are to
talk to
like
just excellent that's not true on the
street and you expect them to have all
the data all the
okay that one that's not true you don't
know anything about my channel i i do i
don't know i'm just i'm just observing i
know i know i'm saying i do live youtube
shows four days a week where i tell
girls the topics i say come i like to
debate
let's talk about it
and they still don't have the facts data
and statistics because it doesn't back
up what they believe and i'm saying i do
this four to four times a week i've done
it for three months
and i've i've i've never had a girl
really bring in many facts data or
statistics it's always just what she
feels and what she believes individual
stories and exceptions to the rules
you know um
do you
when you say you you have your live
stream you just
have uh do you invite them before or do
you uh just ask them on the line so so
no i um it's like planned so so today i
have i'll ask you actually if you want
to come um i do live streams in a studio
in london and so it's tuesday wednesday
thursday saturday i do it four days a
week at eight o'clock at night and we
say this is the topic come on and talk
about it i say i like people like for
you you'd be the perfect guest because
you don't agree i like people that don't
agree i bring them so
i'm saying but it's very rare that they
come with any data like it's always just
this is what i feel and what i think
my producer ish wants me to say a
comment that i just said to him
when girls say like a whole lot of
nothing i just feel like it's like
chickens
like chickens
well
that was fun
i guess
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this girl comes up to me after we're
done and keeps asking me these questions
and i'm like man ma'am i don't argue for
free how many times do i have to say
this
i'm done filming i'm trying to
skedaddle and she just keeps
asking me i'm like let me let me go
[Music]
well i'm i'm done filming for the day so
if you watch
it next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah if is their actions just supported
that
[Music]